au lac et à la migros tu me touches plus
jamais c'est bon les amis aujourd'hui on
est avec toi ont charbon jour vient du
jabron enfin les revenus il ya un moment
déjà on est en forme c'était cool ça
t'as plus écoute c'était nul à chier
parlons-en par mon sens il est là nous
sommes sur tekken parce qu'on n'a pas
dit à quel journal est joué souvenez
vous on s'étaient affrontés sur tekken
au japon
c'est lucas salut qu'à aux chars dans la
vidéo j'ai mis tous les moments où je
gagnais mais ils gagnaient aussi
beaucoup donc tekken qui sort en france
quand l'eau sinon le 2 juin celle de
joie on a aujourd'hui une version sous
les yeux parce que bandai-namco sont dit
[ __ ] leur combat ils sont
impressionnants quand ils jouent ils
sont trop forts ces deux maïs on veut
qu'ils montrent à la france entière
comme le vrai jo japon comment jouer
ouais ils ont jamais dit ça reviens
quand tu touches milieu pour faire cette
vidéo je te propose pour ce premier
combat un grand classique
un tour de chauffe [ __ ] internautes
non moi je te propose un animal fight
d'entrée de jeu pour nos médias parce
que les gens adorent les pandas les gens
adorent les os et il adore le cumin
épices et on on s'appelle qu'humain le
document se veut dire cette blague tombe
à l'eau est bas qui gagne alors est-ce
qu'une embrouille de mon frère au japon
oui mais je n'arrive pas à faire en bas
jusqu à droite j'ai l'impression que ça
va vers la gauche ou au fait ça que j'ai
du mec j'arrêtais pas de sauter je
faisais pas exprès je voulais je le
véritable arcade bien sûr et puis et
puis lorsque tu ne rates tu veux ok le
loing gouroun42 doublé dans des crimes
de douch
[ __ ] c'est la vanne sur les pistes qui
n'a pas plu non bien joué et appellent
réflexe là j'en ai ma claque le dos
comme quand on était petits travers de
la vie
le panda ne gagna round cutter lundi à
tyson ritter time's up quoi on en est là
on joue tellement en mode défensif qu'on
arrive au tamisage attention lors il
faut le putsch le recopier du losc est
un match là mais les autres se loge de 6
à changer donc ta mère je n'ai pas
l'équipe de la foresterie
l'ours a le dessus sur le panda et le
mérite vu cette danse clairement une au
mérite bon alors maintenant combat à
thème peut faire une valeur sûre gros
seins ça lui laisse un très large choix
de personnages 50% du duel tu as dit
gros seins du ruisseau
du coup on va partir sur une joue avec
les flèches tout aussi celle là ouais je
avec le flash - vous avez comme j'essaie
d'apprendre petit à petit pour essayer
de le tas d'autres questions non c'est
bon ça va je le conduis une citation cup
4 plus est vous excellent attention
attention parce que la rendant la phase
sérieuse de jeu a alors même qu'on a
fini pas de try hard deuxième combat
banques étaient prêts bannon du coup
allez vas-y sa part sur un bo liste tu
veux je suis à fond avec toi non j'ai
retenu aucun truc car je sens un bon ok
je saisirai effet de serre ouais c'est
pas mal attends moi je te conseille de
feu voilà au hall à l'origine de ce
crime
un combat excellent apport du temps mais
je discute plus c'était pure petit bois
celle là on la refait parce que je
m'habitue à bord parce que là ça va pas
du tout bien tout comme mes couches moi
malc annoncé luc dumont est ce que juste
tu peux me laisser trouver des excuses
mais couche on voit la main de kaboré au
scrutin je cherche mon gars [ __ ] c'est
dur là c'est dur ce qui se passe au jeu
abonnez vous abonnez vous à une phase de
combat
non on en fait ça ou comment t'as fait
ça c'est pas vrai
je reviens dans lequel il a retrouvé ses
petits combos et oui et quand ils vont
tomber je peux dire que j'en ai un autre
qui va tomber il s'appelle le respect at
et des gâteaux [ __ ] tu venais de route
ok ok ok bien jouer de teint très beaux
plans très très bien joué c'est pour
bien jouer mayling 5
florent va faire un combat on compte
celui qui a la plus grande coupe de
cheveux sa part soins et hachey des
jaloux parce que ma coupe de cheveux
pour enquête on va appeler ça le combo
la coupe de cheveux tu es jaloux parce
qu'on coupe de cheveux plus grande soit
pas jaloux elle est plus grande et en
plus moi j'ai encore des cheveux de
couleur taupe est tien rp zen le bloa
faisait de la teinture la teinture mon
pote cette question avec moi j'ai
compris c'est qu'il n'a pas de portée à
part sa coupe de cheveux il ya un autre
cas ma portée olalala mais c'est bien
c'est parti comme ça car select je ne
prends plus jamais un mec a une grande
coupe de cheveux aux géorgiens le
covoiturage est une grosse pêche mon
gars non j'ai appuyé bien jouer au foot
à quand tu m'envoies comme de la salade
mec s'en bat les couilles sewell page
d'accueil à dans le crâne chauve à les
moeurs au nommé il a fait quoi il a
voulu forme d'abord il a voulu fin de la
mort s'est pas passé bien supporté le
sous-continent tout l'habitude me retire
au plus sacrant sa rage et c'est ça
j'aime je me nourris ta haine vas-y lan
ça me rend plus fort allez là on est
bien venir acheter plus de nourriture
ça fait une heure dix qu'on joue florent
je te propose une gamme chacun ça fait
10 fois je fais ça en fait chaque
adversaire préféré se taire il tu as le
droit de ne pas parler c'est la game du
trail arthur a juste le droit de réagir
à la fin d'une manche c'est tout tout
tout c'est ok c'était parti d'après
brian j'ai pris l'eau c'est parti c'est
la belle
tu n'es plus sur mon testament
olam est finie bas et coutumes avaient
acculé c'était un moment instant
plusieurs attend que ça vous a un
merveilleux moment j'ai adoré perdent
façon je suis habitué finalement sur les
jeux vidéo je perds toujours tenir jouer
n'était pas la mienne au ciel vous a plu
vous dis à bientôt du prochaine vidéo à
bientôt florent deux prochaines vidéos à
bientôt et quand je me serai entraîné
enfin peut-être là veut revendre mais
parce qu'ils sont créés d'avancé je suis
frustré savoyarde et portez vous bien la
trémie presse
[Musique]